okay hi friends welcome back to Linux
networking command episode 3 so friends
if you remember in the previous session
we have discussed 10 Linux networking
command and in today's session also we
are going to discuss another P Linux
networking command and it is definitely
going to helpful for you but guys if
you're new to this Channel please don't
forget to like share and subscribe the
channel and press the Bell icon for the
latest notification friend so please do
subscribe to this channel to grow
together my friend right so let's start
the session so as you can see the first
command is SSH key genain uh hyphen T
RSA so friend if you remember like
suppose if you have to authenticate
between two server okay so generally SS
key gen why we use to generate manage
and convert authentication keys for SSH
means if you have to log in from this NC
controller let me make it a little bit
bigger so you'll understand better okay
to this Splunk indexer node okay so uh
then how we are going to make sure that
we should be able to login from this NC
server to this plun indexer node without
having any password right it should be
passwordless so in that case we generate
SSH key gen my friend where we'll be
deploying our uh private key with the
ncble server and the public key should
be in the Splunk indexer noes so let's
see how we can achieve this one okay so
first let's
uh being a root user okay you can see
I'm already a root user who am I you can
see I'm a root user and what command I'm
going to execute over here is SSH
hyphen
e right hyphen T RS a my friend okay so
it's going to so here you just need to
give a
enter enter because there was already a
file over there so I have just overwrite
that file my friend okay so let's go to
this directory and see what is there
okay CD okay and just do a LS hyph
LTR correct so you can see there is a
public key and there is a private key so
if you do a cat of this public key
correct so you are going to get this one
my friend so friends now what we are
going to do is now we are going to copy
this public key to the Splunk indexer
node my friend let me show show you how
we can achieve this one so you need to
run this command just copy this command
anyways I'm going to put this command uh
into the description so you can use this
one okay just put this command over here
as you know I'm doing the I'm taking
this public key the same from the path
you can see this path only I'm using and
which user means I'm going to log to
this and as of now you can see who am I
I'm a root user over here and what I'm
going to do over here is you can see
right the IP of This Server if I do if
confete okay you can see 211 correct so
run this command and see what is
coming so it's asking yes just make a
yes over here so and it's asking the
password first time it's going to ask
you the password okay so give the
password so uh you can see now try
logging into the this machine okay and
uh you can check whether it's added or
not okay so where we need to be go my
friend Dot SSH correct and just do a
lsph LTR over here so you can see there
is a authorized key over here right and
just do a cat of this authorized
key so you can see clearly if you add at
last here it's coming as a local host
local domain my friend okay so friends
uh now you can see we have deployed the
uh your public key to the Splunk indexer
node to the Linux machine or any Linux
machine now you can check directly
whether you'll be directly loging from
this machine to this machine without or
you can say passwordless okay just I'm
doing ssh what I'm doing root okay or
you can give the direct IP also 192 168
do 72 dot to1 one my friend okay so you
can see directly I have logged into this
machine and uh if if I do if config okay
so you can see now the IP is Chang right
so I'm into this machine this is this
machine IP right so this is how we can
do the passwordless authentication my
friend most of you I'm guanting you that
don't know this process okay so I
explain you how to do it with ease and
why I have done this one you'll come to
know in the next command my friend okay
so let's come out of this one from the
host machine the connection is closed
from the host machine okay and we are
again back to the which machine we are
back to the this machine andal
controller my friend okay
so uh friends let's move on to the next
command the next command is SCP command
and until unless if you don't do SSS
authentication you won't be able to run
this command this is for sure you are
going to get an error okay so the reason
behind that one this is also a trouble
shooting my friend so the reason behind
that one because your SSH is
authentication is not configured
properly okay so let let me copy a file
from this server to the other server
under tra directory or any directory you
can take it SCP SCP stands for secure
copy my friend that is remote file copy
program okay so this is also one Linux
networking command my friend okay so
here what I'm going to do is I'm just or
directly let's run this command okay no
need to do anything right just clear
this one my friend okay so what I'm
going going to do over here is uh just
see is there any file over here okay LS
LTR so I don't have a okay you can see I
have a file 1.txt SCP I'm going to give
this file correct and where you want to
copy I want to copy to
root at the rate of
168 do
72. 211 colons /tmp my friend okay and
uh just enter so you can see it's
showing 100% it's copy and if you go to
This Server okay just clear everything
here and just go to TMP right and you
can come to know your file 1 do PHT is
compy okay so friends uh let's move on
to the next command the next command is
ipf hyph NG okay so this command
basically used for interactive colorful
IP land monitoring my friend okay and
one more thing uh before executing this
command you are not going to get this
command in your any of the Linux
distribution by default so you need to
explicitly install this uh ipf command
okay and for that you need to configure
your repository so for that I have
multiple videos you can go through that
one how to configure y repository or
from2 also you can configure right so
even in the previous session also I have
explained you how to register with red
hat Network my friend okay if you don't
know just ask in the commment I'll
answer okay so let's execute this
command so just run the command my
friend
IP t r
AF and you don't need to give any Gap in
between enter so you can see this kind
of a uh as I said clearly uh colorful IP
landan monitor will come and here uh you
can make your uh suppose you want to
move on to if you want to click here
okay so you want to see for your
interface okay you can see uh in a
colorful how many packets everything you
can see properly how many packets we are
delivering how many bites are there all
runtime you can see over here okay and
if you just want to come out just press
Q okay you'll come out of it and uh this
is how we can use this landan uh station
monitor also you can use it okay so this
the these are the datas you can see with
this command a runtime data you'll be
able to see okay nobody is going to show
this things to you friend okay so please
subscribe to channel more and more okay
so thank you
uh uh friends let's move on to the next
command the next command is LS off
command hyphen I and we are going to see
Port 8090 is listening or not so this is
the list of open files for Port
8090 we need to check and one more thing
before this one so you cannot check this
one directly why I'm able to check over
here let me show you so if I do a Java
okay hyph version
okay so you can see I have already
installed open jdk and I have already
installed Tomcat so how to install tomat
if you want me to show then do more and
more comment okay so definitely I'm
going to make a video how to install
tomcat and it's going to beneficial for
the product support engineer and the
application support even for the devops
engineer my friends so if you wish
please let me know definitely I'm going
to make a video if you want how to
install Tomcat okay but but let's come
to the command that is how we can
execute this command my friend okay so
I'm going to run the command called LS
of hyphen I and then colon 8090 this is
the default Port I'm using for the Tom
Cat and you can
see uh open messaging means this port is
listening and but there is no list of
open files for this one okay as of now
so let's move on to the next command my
friend the next command is etth tool and
you need to give the interface name here
I have given eth Z but whatever the
interface you have first check that one
and give that one so why we use this
command to display or change the
ethernet card setting okay so let's see
how it works my friend so let's clear
this one and first what we need to see
what is your interface so your interface
is which one your interface is this one
and what command we need to run is eth
tool and you need to give the interface
name enter so you can see it's clearly
that link is detected yes this is what I
was uh explaining in one of my video
Linux 100 plus interview question and
answer where I I was troubleshooting uh
at a data link layer okay you know this
one uh so if you can see link is
detected Yes means your network cable is
absolutely fine okay means there is no
issue correct so these are the details
you can get it with the at tool command
uh with your interface name you need to
give okay so friend let's move on to the
next command and the next command is ARP
hyph a what does this command do means
display or modify the ARP cacher my
friend okay so let's see how it
works first clear this one ARP hyphen a
okay so you can see this is how you can
going to get the detail this is your
default gateway and how it's showing
your interface and how right everything
it's going to show you over here with
the ARP command correct address
resolution protocol if you want to know
more about this one just do a ARP my
friend and you can come to know this is
the system ARP cach
okay right you can read more about this
one here okay just come out of this one
clear this
one and uh let's move on to the next
command my friends so most of you are
aware of this command that is host name
CTL status command this command we use
to control the system host name and
related setting my friend okay let's see
how it works so host name
CTL status okay Enter so you can see
clearly as of now I have not said the uh
post name till now I'll show you that
also okay this is why I have keep it
pending for you okay so don't worry
about this one every command has its own
use also so we'll Implement those
command according to the
requirement so it's a VMware machine
okay you know and it's using a VMware
platform so this is why it's giving all
the detail what red hat I'm using that
is 9.3 all the details it's using what
kernel I'm using right so all the
details you are going to get and this is
a virtual machine this is why we it's
it's giving you as a hardware platform
uh Hardware uh platform as a VMware
virtual platform my friend okay okay
friends let's move on to the next
command that is c/c resolve. command uh
basically it's a file which you see okay
and this command or you can say this
file we use it to manage DNS information
here you need to give your DNS name
server okay and see what happened is
when whenever you configure a machine
okay that machine has to authenticate
with a DNS server and that DNS server
name should be in this file M that we
also call it as a name server okay okay
so let me show you what information we
are getting over here so let's clear
this one that/ Etc and
resolve doc so as you can see as the
name server is this one but this is a
gateway this is not a name server means
I have not at all configured the DNS
server over here so as soon as I'll
configure the DNS server and when I'll
be configuring this machine okay so I am
going to to use that same name server
for this virtual machine my friend and
this is how you can resolve your host to
IP and IP to host but for that one you
need to configure your DNS server so
this thing I'm going to show you don't
worry about this one in the DNS
troubleshooting of Linux 100 plus
interview question and answer my friend
so every command I said has a dependency
so you need to wait for this one don't
worry so uh why we use now you know the
importance of/ Etc res.com file okay so
friends let's move on to the next
command that is MTR command this is not
MTR Masala okay this is MTR command so
this command we use it for Network
diagnostic tool uh so let me show you
how it works so if you do a MTR just do
a
google.com Okay so you are going to get
a output like this it helps helps to
display mode restart static stick order
of field right packets lost right
everything average best worst everything
is going to show you over here this is
why it's also called it as a network
diagnostic tool and this is very very
important command my friend okay if you
want to diagnose your network then you
need to use MTR command my friend
okay so let's come out of this one I
press Q so don't ask me in the comment
how you are coming out of those commands
you need to press Q to come out of these
commands my friend okay let's move on to
the next command my
friend so the next command is IW there
is other command also you have heard of
IW config but that command is deicated
so I would suggest use IW command and
there is a option also which you need to
use with IW so that is Dave so normally
IW command is more powerful compared to
your IW config it's more or L same only
okay but this is more uh better compared
to IW config so this is used for
configure wireless network interface
okay and when I we use da means to
display the information about Wireless
uh interfaces my friend okay so let's
see how it works so first I'm only going
to run the IW so we are not getting the
output over here but if you do IW da
correct it's not giving you the output
the reason behind that we don't have a
Wireless setup over here okay this is
why we are not going to get any we are
not having any Wireless interfaces
correct so this is why we are not
getting any output my friend okay
friends I'm ending up the session here
only I hope you like this session my
friend and if you like the session then
please don't forget to like share and
subscribe the channel and press the Bell
icon for the latest notification my
friend and please just stay tuned to my
channel for more updates and and just do
take care of your loved ones till then
Jin and bye-bye my friend